cédric beidou citroën qui s'élance sur
les routes du département de l'allier
est conduite par l'un des rares
constructeurs de voitures de compétition
de formule 1 française guy ligier le
vichy choix s'est battu avec toute son
équipe pendant la saison pour gagner
bilan positif puisque trois éclatante
victoire sont inscrites à son palmarès
de ce voyage
lorsque guy ligier décompresser un peu
il aime à retrouver sa vie de famille
avec sa femme ils partagent une
véritable passion pour ces quatre chiens
mais là encore c'est une impitoyable
compétition qui s'engage entre les
animaux pour obtenir les faveurs du
patron
hop hop
guy ligier à leur bilan de cette saison
de rang péter mullin je crois pouvoir
dire que c'est une saison pour nous qui
a été une grande saison qui était une
saison est positive puisque comme vous
le savez nous avons gagné trois grands
prix et pour nous c'était fondamental de
démontrer aux gens qui nous suivait avec
beaucoup de sympathie d'ailleurs que
nous étions capables de gagner ça je
crois que la saison 1979 à ce point de
vue là a certainement à si notre écurie
et cesse et c'est le principal
en définitive nous nous sommes
essoufflés et je m'en explique
le budget de recherche que nous avions
pour pour cette année était largement
dépassée et il aurait fallu que je
puisse réembaucher quelques personnes de
plus et lauzen était complètement
fatigués et on n'a pas pu suivre le
rythme des deux ferrari
et qu'est ce qui vous pousse justement à
vous battre pourquoi les voitures ligier
sont toujours sur les circuits on vous
savez c'est très simple j'ai toujours eu
l'esprit de compétition puisque depuis
mon plus jeune âge fait du sport
la compétition fait partie mais surtout
avec une équipe qui qui répond
jean-michel qu'est ce qui représente
pour vous écouter les chiens je crois
que c'est un un bon refuge
les chiens c'est mes amis les bêtes ce
sont ces c'est véritablement mes amis
parce que avec les chiens et les bêtes
on se trompe pas c'est quand ils vous en
quand il vous aime c'est jusqu'au bout
c'est pas c'est pas un peu que je sois
perdant ou gagnant quand je rentre ici
c'est toujours les mêmes j'ai hâte de
les voir il va pourquoi toute votre
enfance il ya des peuples et d'animaux
oui j'ai été élevé dans une ferme à la
terre j'ai beaucoup d'amitié
vous avez quatre chiens ou cinq chiens
et une passion commune avec votre femme
c'est tout à fait ma femme adore les
bêtes et croyez moi la maison d'ailleurs
voilà ça c'est la patronne d'abord c'est
d'ailleurs c'est elle qui commande c'est
valia qui commande c'est le sait la
chaîne elle règne sur les gros les
petits
absolument elle est là et pira il ya le
car les eaux alors qu'est ce que c'est
que le chien il est assis bruits disant
ah bah léon léon c'est tout à fait autre
chose léon ses joyeux d'ailleurs il est
pas là mais il doit être il doit pas
être loin mais c'est un chien qui aiment
la liberté et il la prend
mais je dois dire que il n'est pas il
est très intéressant il faut lg plus le
temps de m'en occuper
c'est un garçon à découvrir absolument
et pourquoi je dirais c'est votre chien
à bout c'est le chien bo de femmes c'est
ma femme qui a été le chercher mais je
crois que je ne sais pas pourquoi mais
il s'entend bien avec moi mais
malheureusement je ne voit pas assez
souvent pour le disant le qui se sentent
un peu plus en sécurité
vous avez le même caractère je crois oui
je crois c'est instinct libéral et gémit
j'attache beaucoup d'importance à la
liberté de la volonté assez bourru mais
pas méchant non pas l'union
je
il y est si un jour vous ne pouviez plus
construit voiture qu'est ce que vous
feriez écouter ce que je puis vous dire
c'est que jusqu'au dernier moment je
j'essaierai de conte sur des voitures
mais il est certain que si jeunes pour
des raisons qui sont en dehors de ma
volonté je ne pouvais plus continuer
alors je me retirerai très certainement
dans à la campagne où je suis né et où
j'irai élever des bêtes avec votre balle
et gien absolument absolument c'est
fondamental